c'est bientôt la troisième édition du
festival play it again play it again
c'est un festival de grands films
classiques du cinéma et ça sera du 5 au
11 avril ces films ont été restaurés et
vous pourrez venir découvrir sur grand
écran
nous avons nous au grenier à sel
sélectionné trois de ces défis du
festival il y a tout d'abord pour les
enfants à partir de 5 ans alice comme et
c'est un programme des courbes premier
court métrage de walt disney ce sera le
mercredi 5 et le dimanche 9 avril
nous avons aussi les hommes préfèrent
les blondes marie monroe sera donc au
grenier à sel le vendredi 7 avril et le
troisième film sera indochine avec
catherine deneuve et vincent perez le
film a été restauré en ultra haute
définition 4k et ce sera le dimanche 9
avril à 20h45 vous retrouver tout ça sur
notre site internet cinéma grenier à sel
points comme je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]